we've got some very exciting news that
we've been waiting almost two years to
share with you
finally after a lot of effort and hard
work we're ready to unveil our latest
invention
the brand new app from the school of
life
we've asked a lot of you what you wanted
from an app from us and you've told us
so we've gone and built it for you
this is the best of the school of life
in your pocket anywhere anytime filled
with all the wisdom playfulness and
insight you've come to expect from us
think of our app as like your own
personal therapist always on hand giving
you guidance inspiration daily quotes
videos and the best ideas for making
sense of yourself and the world
even better the more you use the app the
more it gets to know you
so that it will be on hand with just the
right bit of helpful information
whenever you need it most
apologies for bragging a bit it's not
our normal style
but we can't help but be proud of what
we've done and we really hope you'll
enjoy our app as much as we do
please follow the links below to find
out more and give it a go on your phone
available on ios and android
we don't think you'll regret it
you